welcome to LED live today we will be
delving into the topic of social justice
and we're here to answer the question in
this day and age is justice enough find
out on this episode of LED live this is
LED live the show where we use the light
of Christ to expose the darkness found
in media and our culture today and today
I'd like to take the time to welcome a
very special guest this is my mom
mama calendar thank you so much for
joining the show and helping me out with
this kind of topic this is where candy
gets all of her wisdom this is so true
we have heard your requests and are
working very hard to make them a reality
for all the Spanish speakers out there
little lights studios has a Spanish
channel it's called little lights and
espanol anyone who speaks Spanish you
can go over there and watch little light
studios productions in your native
tongue and the goal is for all of our
English content to be translated into
Spanish and can be sent out to the
spanish-speaking community so if your
your Spanish speaker and know someone
who's Spanish you can check out the link
in the description box below to head
right over to little light studios and
espanol and while you're down there
there are also links to our patreon
account and to our different t-shirts if
you'd like to support us financially and
michelle here has been working very hard
on a new project would you like to tell
us about that yeah sure so as you guys
see here it's a sticker this is another
way to witness besides our t-shirt right
now we have stickers so you can get it
it's the isn't in the district yeah
we'll have that in description box below
to the description below and
help support us awesome so we hope we
see these on lots of cars okay so um you
may notice the energy is a little
different on the show today who are
tackling a a pretty heavy topic that I
believe all of us should be involved in
and I'm thankful that you guys are here
to discuss this with me and to get
different viewpoints and I encourage all
of you to stay till the end to get a
holistic view to understand where were
coming from so we encourage we encourage
that prejudice and social justice are
very volatile topics actually those
topics I wouldn't have touched before
with a ten-foot pole I was just like
I'll stay quiet you know angle it's like
wherever side do you come at the topic
there's always gonna be somebody that
just doesn't like what you say that was
true but that was before and I've done a
lot of growing and I've realized I am a
black woman living in America I don't
have to realize I can look at my skin
every day and see that but I'm also a
Christian living today and I do not have
the option of staying quiet you know
especially on this platform each one of
us every Christian should be vocal about
in Justices right now in the world today
what do you guys think yeah yeah it's
unfortunate that something like this
happens because there is a lot of
injustice with a variety of things but
then you know it's like yeah we need to
speak up and the fact that we're still
dealing with this in our society today
in 2020 right it shouldn't be we
shouldn't be dealing with these topics
yeah you know Jesus said how you treat
the least of these you tree like me you
know so nobody should be treated least
you know we're we're all the we're all
one in Christ Jesus he says there's
neither Jew nor Greek you know we're all
the same and I watched a documentary
just two days ago of a guy who he's been
carrying a cross around for like a long
time traveling the world and he started
it like 50 years ago
and a cop came up to him because he was
praying with a black man he was holding
his hands and praying with him and a cop
came up here and said what are you doing
and Mississippi holding hands with a
black man he said this is America I'm
free yeah I can pray with whoever I want
to and he got put in a car and taken
them to the station and I was just like
I can't even comprehend that right so
you don't have to be black to realize
that something isn't right
something's going on on May 25th 2020
George Floyd a 46 year old black man
died after a white police officer
holding his knee on Floyd's neck pinned
him to the pavement while Floyd was in
handcuffs in the days that followed
public outrage grew over what some
protesters and lawmakers said is another
case of police brutality against a black
man unrest has since erupted in
Minneapolis and has spread across the
nation and across the world I'd like to
show you a clip of what took place that
day just a warning the content that is
about to be shown is explicit viewer
discretion is advised good I'm getting
too calm man I will
you don't get any karma get up get home
oh hey
I can't okay y'all let's do it again he
in front on you you can't win money you
can't make it man up dude I know you
ain't never listen that's for me my
stomach hurt when they turn everything
is water something
haha
ah it's just immediately maddening yeah
you know I mean somebody pleading for
their life especially like a police
officer is supposed to serve and protect
that's their job is like you know
they're there to help preserve life and
peace and safety for everyone and then
you see this situation where someone who
is supposed to be the you know person
that Emmitt ministers that they are
totally disregarding human life yeah so
I watched a video that the Washington
Post put out it included the events that
led up to the death of George Floyd and
you know the people who were involved in
it and all of that and I could hardly
make it through the video I had to
literally pray and ask God to quiet the
rage that was building inside of me
because that could have been my cousin
you know I couldn't my uncle that could
have been me and the pain just sitting
with that thought it's just you can't
even explain I can't even explain what
I'm feeling right now it in in viewing
another clip like this it's it's
exhausting it really is exhausting and
when you look and you you you understand
that we as a people are seen as the
problem that is the issue and this is
the reality that we live in today and
response to this the response to this is
utter chaos
check out this clip
[Music]
this is not a protest this is not in the
spirit of Martin Luther King jr. this is
chaos it's not right Matt it's not right
y'all pull us over for broken taillight
sued us harasses we got kids I'm hurt
I'm angry but I ask you well Michael I'm
gonna start off in the West Coast in
Oakland California it was the first
night of protests there and initially
they were peaceful but then what
happened Michael is thousands get went
into a highway they completely blocked
both lanes of traffic that whole
standoff lasted about 20 minutes after
that we know that several businesses
were set on fire now these are larger
businesses we know that a bank was set
on fire also a mercedes-benz dealership
and a few other chains in those protests
there in Oakland now let's move over to
Los Angeles where over there it was the
third night of protests in the city and
again initially they started off very
peacefully but then soon into the night
at around 8 o'clock in the evening
actually protesters began hurling
bottles and rocks at police then at
around 9:30 at night the LAPD declared
for an for unlawful assembly for all of
downtown Los Angeles and asked everyone
to go home and ask businesses to close
however that did take quite a while for
people to kind of clear out the area and
then when they did Michael what was left
behind was graffiti all over cars and
businesses and much of the graffiti said
I can't breathe and of course we know
that those are some of the last words
that George that came out of George
Floyd's mouth before he died Michael so
those were the protests on the west
coast what about the east and Midwest as
well because certainly we saw the
violence in many different cities that's
just it and I'm going to take you over
to New York because that City there has
seen protest for quite some time this
was I think it was the second day of
protests there we know that there were
injuries on beau
sides on the sides of police and of
course on the sides of protesters as
well we know thousands demonstrated
outside the Barclays center and then
things turned a very violent we know
that police even responded with pepper
spray on the protesters and / and
protesters there Michael responded by
burning some police vehicles it was like
you just get to the breaking point man
it's like I remember hearing Tupac talk
about it he was saying you know how long
can you just sit there and and talk
about it and nothing gets done
it just gets bottled up and it's gonna
explode like that's where we're at like
to me it just seems like you know when
when the people that are supposed to be
there sort of like the authority in the
room right and they're in the wrong
where do you go from there like who is
supposed to be an authority over them to
me it's like our government needs to
take a look at this situation and and
and at least have some sort of
punishment for the people that are
engaging in this and being like listen
if you are a police officer and and and
you are caught doing this I mean it's
just immediate like you know life
imprisonment or whatever I if I stopped
it real quick exactly just that label of
police officer I don't know where that
protection is coming from just because
you're a police officer you're not
treated as civilian who would just
commit murder I mean you can literally
be doing everything right and still run
the risk of getting killed by suspicious
I was you can tell it's not like it was
manslaughter not like an accidents and
they're like just kneeling on the whole
time he's begging for his life the
officers in me was on George Floyd's
neck for eight and a half minutes and
George Floyd is in cuffs not resisting
asking for water saying he can't breathe
saying he's in pain that's manslaughter
you know it was interesting I was
listening on the radio and they were
talking about this whole experience in
did you notice the police officer had
his hand in his pocket and a martial
artist called in to the to the radio
station and said do you know why his
hand was in the pocket and the lady was
like no I I wouldn't know and she said
well I was in martial arts and you learn
to use leverage of your body and so he
had leverage of his leg and if
put your hand in your pocket you're now
using your whole upper body to push down
even harder and that's why his hand was
in his pocket he was administering as
much force as he possibly could which
yes makes you think and there's you know
other police officers standing around
there I mean at what point do you as a
police officer shove the guy off and be
like I don't care if I'm gonna get you
know fired reprimanded whatever like
someone's about to die here
we just affect they're all just standing
around nonchalantly it's disturbing yeah
I mean there's no years ago I adopted a
saying from someone one of my mentors
how you do one thing is how you do
everything and when we look around at
how most not all but most policemen
behave in society in general they go
through the red lights they go through
the stop signs it's as though the law is
not for them so they break all the laws
but they hold the civilians to the law
so this is just another expression of
that mindset it's good because in their
minds they can do no wrong so they're
not going to disrespect one law and
respect another they're just all noise
and so they're just above all of the
laws that's how the bad ones behave and
this is an illustration at that point in
my mind
the thing is not all police officers are
like that but it's the bad ones that you
see in the news it's the bad ones
getting all the publicity and it's the
same with this when it comes to you know
like black on black crime which even
like I don't even like that phrase it
doesn't make any sense cuz when white
people go at it they don't call it a
white on white crime but um it's like
you know what's portrayed what's pushed
being pushed out then becomes a label
for the entire community and it's on
both sides with police of police
officers as well as the black community
I want nothing more than for this police
officer to be tried and given the same
punishment as any other murderer
[Music]
what's frightening is the response of
the protesters I just I I don't
understand what they're trying to
achieve by destroying their own
neighborhoods their own communities the
same people that they would like to
protect that they want justice for is
this are the same people that they're
hurting because the communities need
those education buildings you know they
need those stores they need reasons
riots happening in predominantly black
communities yeah Atlanta so 50% of
there's like you know upper echelon
white population question I'm not a
hundred essentially rioting there
because it's like yeah you're hurting
your own you know people yeah in in and
and what is that gonna accomplish
exactly so what's thing the thing is you
know taxpayer dollars are going up in
flames and it's gonna be taxpayer
dollars that go to rebuild these things
so I I don't really see the the point
how quickly we forget our history and
what we were able to accomplish
effectively with peace and I don't
believe this is the right response at
all listen carefully to what the mayor
of Atlanta had to say about her city and
for some perspective let's go to the
mayor of Atlanta who in no way wanted to
see her city on fire and was very
outspoken about it and also had
perspective on why what she doesn't like
happening was happening and it's very
important to hear mayor Keisha Lance
bottoms listen to her
I am a mother I am a mother to four
black children in America one of whom is
18 years old and when I solved the
murder of George Floyd I hurt like a
mother would hurt and on yesterday when
I heard there were rumors about violent
protests in that land I did what a
mother would do I called my son and I
said where are you I said I cannot
protect you and black boys shouldn't be
out today so you're not gonna out
concern me and out care about where we
are in America
I wear this each and every day and I
pray over my children each and every day
so what I see happening on the streets
of Atlanta is not Atlanta this is not a
protest this is not in the spirit of
Martin Luther King jr. this is chaos a
protest has purpose when dr. King was
assassinated we didn't do this to our
city so if you love this city this city
that has had a legacy of black mayors
and black police chiefs and people who
care about this city where more than 50%
of the business owners and metro Atlanta
are minority business owners if you care
about this city then go home and pray
that somebody like Reverend Beasley will
come and talk to you and give you some
instructions on what a protest should
look like and how you effects your
weight change in America this police
chief made a video on yesterday pull it
up on YouTube
where she said she was appalled to watch
the murder of George Floyd this woman
did that you're not honoring the legacy
of Martin Luther King jr. and the civil
rights movement you're not protesting
anything running out with brown liquor
in your hands breaking windows in this
city see I kill a Mike on half the
Westside so when you burn down this city
you're burning down our community if you
want change in America going register to
vote show up at the polls on June 9th do
it in November that is the change we
need in this country you are disgracing
our City you are disgracing the life of
George Florida and every other person
who has been killed in this country we
are better than this we're better than
this as a city we are better than this
as a country go home go home in the same
way I can protect my son on yesterday I
cannot protect you out in those streets
you're doing nice at our police officers
you are burning cars you have to face
let's see and then building Ted Turner
started seeing in in Atlanta 40 years
ago because he believed in who we are as
a city there was a black reporter who
was arrested on camera this morning who
works for seeing me and they are telling
our stories and you are disgracing their
building this is not the legacy of civil
rights in America this is chaos and
we're buying into it
this won't change anything we're no
longer talking about the murder of an
innocent man we're talking about how you
burn in police cars on the streets of
Atlanta Georgia go home shut up so many
so many yes so many points it first off
you know justjust I appreciate what
she's saying then this is not the way to
deal with it like if if somebody comes
at you and they're smiling and you're
coming back at them angry it's all of a
sudden gonna make the other person angry
right you kind of just rise to that same
emotional level I teach my kids this
concept all the time you come screaming
and yelling your brother or sister is
gonna come screaming and yelling right
back and then before you know it you're
trying to one-up each other and see
who's gonna dominate in this situation
that doesn't solve anything but if
somebody comes at you screaming and
yelling and they're angry at you and you
come back at them with a smile the whole
situation actually a biblical principle
Solomon the wisest man said the soft
answer turneth or ear ah that's right
that's right I understand that people
are in pain and they're looking for a
release but here's my fare I'm fearing
that we're proving the racists point
we're proving you know the this this
false idea that black people aren't
thinkers that black people are
uncontrollable that black people are
dangerous people when you see those
clips and that's what's in the media
you're not seeing the clips of people
actually trying to protect police
officers you're not seeing the clips of
people trying to reason with each other
no you're seeing the chaos you're seeing
the anger you're seeing the destruction
but what's even more alarming to me is
is you know you see these these riots
and you sees people everybody has a
camera I mean that's what's amazing
about today's today's day and age right
you you can barely get away with
anything because everybody's rolling
around with cameras right and you've got
these guys that are rolling up on these
protests and breaking windows and
smashing stuff and then people run over
to them like hey what are you doing they
flip around they're these white kids
mm-hmm like what are you what are you
doing
inciting even you know it's like their
their their desiring for this thing to
get out of control listen don't don't
don't spray stuff oh here when they go
blame black people for this and black
people didn't do it
this is in reaction to what happened my
question is why didn't something happen
in the midst of the situation yeah when
you have a police officer with his knee
on top of a civilian for
eight-and-a-half minutes no one thought
let me run over and push this guy so
this guy can breathe
let me go and do something what's the
worst I'll happen I'll get arrested sure
but at least the guy lives yeah you know
that's that was what was going through
my mind while is watching this video
why wasn't something done in that
instance why why why is everyone so
quick to jump and set things ablaze
where were those people when when when
George Floyd was on the ground I think
legally in our country you you can be a
citizen and actually arrest a cop right
there disregarding the law yeah well we
own I mean we are the government the
government with we really control people
should be yeah no but I mean you can
make a citizen's arrest
you can we live in America right we live
in America what do they say it's the
land of the free home of the brave but
let's be real in this country it's white
people who are free and the people of
color needs to be brave hmm and the same
things that you're talking about we
should be able to this we can do that
unfortunately it depends on the person
because as I attempt to make this arrest
because I have the right they'll be so
quick to come and arrest me for trying
to enforce the right that I have there's
these are the things we have to think
about that we can't be so quick to say a
on paper I'm allowed to do this
doesn't work that way unfortunately
that's what we're trying to change so
many times you're actually not really
also allowed to to voice teen justices
that you suffer that's why I have never
been chosen to sit on a jurors course
because whenever they interview me and
the guy they always ask you well what do
you do I'm a speech therapist speech
pathologists whether you work in a
school or you have a job aren't you
fortunate that you have a job think
about how many people don't have a job
and my response usually is well I have a
job and I'm grateful for it
but she said that that can only happen
in this land of justice and I usually
respond well it's justice for some hmm
I'm getting the police immense s me what
do you mean justice for some I said well
justice is different in this country
some people actually do get justice and
others of us should get just this they
go and they have the little chatter
outside and they take me to the desk and
doorman says thank you so much for
coming
we'll see you again in four years I have
never been chosen because every time
they bring up something like that I make
sure to let them know that I don't think
the system of justice is truly working
the same for everyone yeah this is
apparently totally true there is there
are a few things that I'd like to
address from what the mayor of Atlanta
said three things in particular one
thing did you catch a she that she said
a protest has purpose and I was powerful
and she said that POTUS has purpose
there is a difference between activism
and advocacy
okay so let's delve into that when you
think of an activist what's the first
thing that comes to mind you think it's
like a protest like signs and when I
think of activism this is what I see
mm-hmm people screaming you know they're
there there's a good cause behind it
mm-hmm but what's black on the streets
they're blocking it
normal way of life because they're just
wanting people to say hey pay attention
to this this this topic yeah when you
think of an advocate what comes to mind
you're like a lawyer lawyer mm-hmm
mediator
these are good words this is what this
is what I think of this is what comes to
mind you know talking it out presenting
a case I like what that mayor said look
I'm here fighting for you this this city
has employed the black community in
influential positions but we can't do
that if you're out there throwing knives
at a police officer you know what I mean
exactly the simplest way I can explain
the difference between an activism and
advocacy is activism is militant
advocacy is a defense and that's what we
need as a black community we need
advocates and you have to be black to
the advocate advocate of the black
community like surely this is the time
for me to listen not talk and then I
realized that that's part of the problem
people like me have to speak up so be
clear I'm not talking about late night
hosts or people who are fortunate like I
am to have a platform I'm talking about
white people white people cannot just
say anymore yeah
I'm not racist and think that that's
enough because it's not it's not enough
because make no mistake this is our
problem to solve how can the black
community dismantle a problem that they
didn't create we shouldn't just be
trying to understand the rage we should
feel the rage now no one wants to see
destruction in their cities it's
frightening and it is hard to watch but
don't let that distract you from the
message of the protesters who have
voices that need to be heard right now
because the things white people
associate with justice help and safety
are often the very opposite for black
and brown people while white people can
generally trust the police to protect
and serve them for black communities the
police force can represent a painful
past of enforcing overtly racist laws
such
segregation and a presence of racial
inequality racial profiling over
policing of communities of color and
most glaringly the use of force on black
citizens something which is too frequent
often deadly and historically without
consequence as a white man I am afforded
all kinds of privileges as the result of
a system that has been built on
injustice I know that I can never truly
understand the pain and the fear that so
many black Americans are forced to enjoy
to simply live but I do know that it's
imperative that those of us with
privilege stand alongside the oppressed
to hear to listen to take time to be
educated and to use our platforms to
amplify their voices but as I said at
the start I feel hopeless I don't have
the answers I don't have gone over
nothing to offer but I know that I want
to do more I want to learn more and let
that be a start
we need more advocacy more conversations
with the right people the people who can
action who the people who actually have
the power to create change
advocates present a case and I believe
that presenting this case creates a
lasting change whereas activists forced
the hand and I believe that that leads
to resentment and that leads to more
hatred we need advocates second thing I
want to bring up is she brought up
Martin Luther King and I want to expand
out the history to even previous to
Martin Luther King all the way up to the
posts in world so after sin entered into
the world after Adam and Eve going
forward in reality unfortunately this is
nothing new what we're experiencing here
today is nothing new and if you study
history every single era had its in
justices yeah my parents didn't like the
smell
let's go all the way back to the days of
Noah so Genesis 6 verse 5 12 and 13 say
and God saw the wickedness of man was
great in the earth and that every
imagination of the thoughts of this half
of his heart was only evil continually
and God looked upon the earth and behold
it was corrupt for all flesh had
corrupted its way upon the earth and God
said to Noah the end of all flesh is
come before me for the earth is filled
with violence through them and behold I
will destroy them with the earth does
that sound familiar is that not where
we're living through right now their
thoughts were evil continually
and the earth was filled with violence
so we talked about Noah let's
fast-forward to the prophecies of what
was going to be happening in Jerusalem
and that what was actually fulfilled in
Jerusalem Isaiah chapter 59 verses 14
through 17 Mikey can read that verse and
judgment has turned away backward and
justice stands afar off for truth has
fallen in the street and equity cannot
enter
yayyyy truth falls and he that departs
from evil makes himself a prey and the
Lord saw it and it displeased him that
there was no judgment right there the
Lord is paying attention isn't that
comforting in a way it is and and that
he's moved because he sees like there's
no justice mm-hmm like here can I read
something to you Psalms eleven five the
Lord tests the righteous but his soul
hates the wicked and the one who loves
violence like that's just an interesting
thought to me that God hates something
that that to me is foreign because we so
often talk about God is love God is love
he's always loving right but it's like
there's something that he absolutely
just cannot stand because violence just
takes it's like it's like if if you're
gonna kill somebody from that point
forward that Souls fate is decided mmm
like they can no longer choose will be
one or whatever it's like that's the
that's the end and and isn't that
interesting that okay you know man was
an upright moral they were able to make
judgment what we lost in the Garden of
Eden was our judgement mm-hm and it
seems like the more that we give up our
sound reason or judgment that's the
closer to Satan's whole you know thing
is he's just lost his judgment yeah two
things should echo God since our God
sent yeah oh you gotta explain that God
you don't physically we have these five
senses that we we see the world we learn
about the world through our senses which
is called the avenue to our souls but
the God sense that we have is our wisdom
that comes from God the type of judgment
that comes through our conscience
because God speaks to us through our
conscience and when that is lost then
anything goes that's almost like why
it's in there first that talks about
their consciences were seared with a hot
iron yeah yeah I mean it might be kind
of a different topic but then partner
will sin you know rejecting that
conscience over and over and over until
in Genesis it says my spirit will not
always strive with man there comes a
point where God realizes that you're not
gonna change and so you know his spirit
leaves and that person has no conscious
the scientific community would call it a
sociopath you know but we know
spiritually
they've just blaspheme the holy spirit
to the point of grieving the Holy Spirit
to the point of them leaving I take this
not to a different level and look at it
from another perspective I don't think
the Holy Spirit ever leaves or withdraws
in the sense that we think about it I
think that when someone continually
rejects the voice of God after why that
voice keeps getting softer and softer
and softer because it becomes easier and
easier to keep doing the wrong thing and
after a while you just don't hear that
voice anymore because it's called
this soft voice you just don't hear it
anymore because you've crowded it out so
often when it comes at one point
you hear silence yes you'd like a hot
iron like calloused eventually those
guitar strings don't hurt your fingers
and that's not because they're callous
penetrate Wow
so it's great about this verses that we
see the Lord fights back you want to
continue Mikey yeah and he saw that
there was no man and wondered that there
was no intercessor therefore his arm
brought salvation to him and his
righteousness it sustained him for he
put on righteousness as a breastplate
and a helmet of salvation upon his head
and he put the garments of vengeance for
clothing and was clad with zeal as a
cloak can you picture that him suiting
up look I just ready them for battle
yeah you know the final picture of Jesus
when he takes off his priestly robes and
puts on his kingly robes and then he's
coming back he's gonna give everyone
according to their deeds and you know
unfortunately some people don't like the
judgment aspect of God but it's merciful
the people that have been wronged for so
long it's like there's got to be justice
you know mm-hmm so the only difference
between back then and throughout history
and now is what think about it what's
the difference because we've seen this
media there you go technology we can
highlight and then if you see that over
it I often wonder I have this kind of
conversation over and over again are we
seeing more racial tension or is it
always been there and we're just able to
like fly that around immediately I think
the second part of what you said yeah I
think it's always it's always been here
and we're just not ready because we have
this global community and everyone has a
camera and a phone and there is the
internet then you see it in real time
mm-hmm that's what I think yeah so the
third point I want to bring up she pled
for people especially black boys to go
home the question I came to my mind was
for those who listened and went home
what now mm-hmm you know your home
you're sitting with this know it what do
you do know I feel like they're not
helping at all you know just sitting
there not speaking out
yeah so so you know and and maybe
forgive my ignorance on this but there's
really no good way to cut it for the
black males anyway if you don't do
anything then your own kind will say you
didn't you know enter into this and
stand up and fight if you do do
something is that really necessarily the
best it's like they're kind of caught it
I understand them what do you do you
know mean like like you feel like
something needs to get done I mean what
a frustrating situation well
maybe since you're gathering somewhere
anyway I mean they advertised on social
media or whatever we're going down here
looting I mean if you're gathered like
that get out of bullhorn and you know
talk about what you want to talk about
but don't destroy stores and stuff so
here's an idea the media is very
effective in stirring the pot right now
what if we use the media to talk about
these issues what if we use a bullhorn
to bring people together you know what I
mean like don't fight this with sticks
and stones but fight this with words and
you know just information yeah yeah I
saw this post on Facebook about this
protest in Miami and the police actually
just kneel down and just look down and
the protest ended up being a peaceful
and you know they talk and I saw a
picture of police hugging the civilians
and then I saw a comment on that and say
you know I watched CNN the whole day and
I did not see this on TV mm-hmm what if
we just put up those nice picture you
know they're actually the peaceful one
that gets a resolution that will inspire
another protestor to do the same mm-hmm
and highlight those as the news outlets
stories you know I mean instead of the
thing that's gonna douse gasoline on to
the fire yeah something that's gonna put
water onto a fire and and calm it down
for sure but one of them I've realized
in terms of what becomes news and media
sensationalism is what sells that's what
gives you greater or high
ratings so for the images that you're
talking about for them to get to people
civilians would have to post those those
would have to become YouTube videos or
private into Internet videos I don't
think we would see much of it at all in
the news accepted something happening to
somebody the the mayor she referred to
the CNN news reporter that was that was
I'm arrested and I actually saw that
video it was a young black gentleman and
he was reporting on what was happening
the police were coming in they had on
there they riot gear and they were
telling the people to move back and
where to stand and the guy was standing
where they had said they could stand and
he was just reporting on what was
happening and the police were coming and
it seems like things were quieting down
and then they approached him and while
they're approaching him he is saying
that the police are approaching him and
they come to him and he says to them
well what do you want us to do just tell
us where you want us to go and they're
just you know tell us what we you know
we got your buddy
next thing you know they were arresting
him hmm
and we didn't know why he was being
arrested so they hand the mic over to
his producer then they arrested the
producer and then he arrested the camera
crew and it took them all down and one
of that was covered on the camera at one
point the person in the studio was
saying our cameras are on the ground we
don't know what's going on and so I mean
I think I saw later that he was he was
released but I'm not sure if they ever
gave a reason for arresting all he was
doing was covering what was happening
and he identified himself who he was who
he was of CNN I would like to see our
government do something this has been a
problem long enough with it there needs
to be somebody that's stepping in and
either educating from the top down and
getting involved and there needs to be
consequences I mean this should
this is this is doing nobody any good
but causing all of us taxpayers billions
of dollars and just destroyed stuff and
a bunch of hatred feelings and it's like
you know I mean that would depth that
would mean that the government would
have to want to stop it I don't know you
know if we would even go there or that
candle or that's what I was going to
bring up I'm glad that you brought it up
too because I don't want to I don't want
to lighten this situation at all but I
do believe that you know we often talk
about how Satan is behind the media and
stuff and and he's the destroyer he want
his the antagonize err and and when you
see like footage of some random white
guy going by and casually just busting
windows and stuff it makes you wonder
like is somebody else enticing this for
a purpose to cause chaos and cause the
vision so that they can you know inflict
stronger laws and things like that right
you know and if there and if there
really is a mindset of people like let's
say it's not the government you know you
know playing both sides or whatever like
this is just random people then that's
even more disturbing to me that we have
a bunch of people running around that
see an opportunity to just create
violence when it has nothing to do with
them that is a problem to me and and you
know it's probably cuz everyone's
playing GTA 5 you know well but what
you're talking about
it's not gonna come from a human
perspective because the Bible tells us
the heart of a man is is deceitful you
see truly wicked and so it has to come
from outside of man and that brings to
mind something I heard pastor IVA mire
say this weekend when he was preaching
and he talked about the first racist
being Satan he went where head back so
he says well how does God describe
himself God describes himself like the
bow in the sky the rainbow has many
colors God made man in his own image
which means that every color of every
race is a representation of God in God's
image
and Satan hates God which means Satan
hates the human race than God created
them so there are no races there's only
one race and that's the human race from
God's perspective so when we Satan pits
people against each other but in actual
fact he hates us all every race he hates
and so he puts one against the other
thinking I'm winning my race is winning
but you're actually losing because the
one who is doing the evil is sinning the
one to whom the evil is being done is
angry and sinning so they're both
sinning and sit on wins in the end
you know it's like we can explain this
from the Christian perspective to the
Christian what do you say to the
non-christian right so I actually broke
up the answer you know what do you do
when you arrive home I broke up my
answer into two one for the non-believer
and one for the Christian specifically
and to the non-believer I would
encourage that person carefully watch
the events that are taking place ask
yourself are things going back to normal
or are they getting worse are they
getting more intense is it just
affecting my city or is it affecting the
entire globe with the combination of the
coronavirus right with the loss of jobs
the economy the continuation of racism
and other social justice issues the
nation marching in the streets the world
I should say marching in the streets
because we're hearing would have what's
happening in Italy we're hearing what's
happening in London in response to what
happened in Minneapolis this is not even
your country you're rioting I'm
questioning where the world is at right
now the world is in turmoil so you have
to ask yourself where is this leading
where is this heading and I'd leave it
at that if a Christian is talking to a
non-christian I leave it at that drop
that seed and have the Holy Spirit work
with that because I'm they may start
asking questions okay where is this
heading yeah
hoosh what what should I be reading what
book should I be reading you know who
should I be praying - where are the
answers where can I find the answers and
to understand these things that we're
talking about you know it's double
behind this and all this type of stuff
to say that to someone who's in pain to
tell them to go home like that's a lot
so just to ask thinking
thought-provoking questions and have the
Holy Spirit lead in that instance and
then my answer to the Christian not just
a black Christians all Christians here
is my response here's my answer we are
charged by Jesus Christ to talk and not
only talk we are charged to live the
solution we're not to dwell on the
problem or even be a parts of the
problem the world is already doing that
they're doing quite an effective job
because these riots will lead to change
it will there will be a push for justice
in the sense that not only was the
officer fired now he's been arrested and
now charges have been made so acts of
justice are happening as a result of
these riots but will justice take away
the pain and the resentments of the
black community
right will justice change the mindset
and the attitude of the racist is
justice enough what about the heart
I don't believe justice is enough at all
I believe that if we're wanting to
change the hearts and the mind of the
human race
the only way that that can happen is a
personal relationship with Jesus Christ
remember at the end of that clip where I
was showing you all the booty the the
acts of the protesters and there was a
black man in a black shirt and he says
I'm not even afraid I'm angry you know
the bible doesn't discount our human
emotions so Bible says be angry feel it
but sin not and which you said is you
know because what do you tell the person
who is afraid the black person is
walking on the street fearful because of
what's going on black person who's angry
what what do you tell them when you have
that relationship with Jesus Christ
you've already determined in your mind
that I am
to live as he asks me and I believe that
he will be there through it all mmm
and you have love in your heart I'm
gonna read it because it was so good she
said perfect love casts out fear when
you have perfect love for Christ and you
believe his promises that love will take
away the fare to be walking through as a
person of color and not be fearful being
angry but not not sinning still
presenting the love of Christ despite
what I'm feeling on the inside
oh what a testimony and and I would say
if you just spend a thoughtful hour just
thinking about the closing moments of
the cross right here we have Jesus
sprawled out in one of the most crazy
torture okay putting your knee on
someone's neck yes that hurts
driving spikes into your hand and
displaying you up in front of everyone
to walk by stark naked that's crazy
right and Jesus is sitting there going
Father forgive them I known they know
not what they're doing I listen to this
verse Matthew 6:15 but if you do not
forgive others their trespasses neither
will your Father in heaven forgive you
we've all trespassed god it's right
every single one of us and by
trespassing god we've all trespassed
each other we've all lied to each other
we've we've we've done horrible and evil
things to each other
so if we can't forgive those kind of
things how is it speaking to the
Christian how is it that we can go to
God and say forgive me of all the stuff
I've done yet I'm totally unwilling to
forgive this person over here it's not
just in our homes it's wherever we go
it's something you need to practice this
isn't easy you know we know we're not
asking for it God even knows he's not
asking for anything easy which is why it
was necessary for Jesus to go through
something like that
as our example and it's why he didn't
just come down to earth and the next day
he was crucified no this was a what a 33
year experience of him being put down of
him having to practice what he preached
I had a experience like first time
happened to my family saw in where I
live in the community sometimes it
happens that you know we have a dog and
the Muslim they don't they don't like
dogs right I'm not trying to make no
Muslim bad but this is just a story so
there's one even the dog was barking in
my house guests guests coming and the
person behind my house he did not like
that so I came to my house actually came
to the door and he tried to hit my dad
because he was going to open it over and
yeah I mean our family is a Chinese
descent too and we're Christians so he
came to the door but my dad was calm he
was like okay you know let's just talk
me son but this guy keep you know trying
to hit him and everything and I saw I
got mad and then so my mom finally came
and you know she got kind of angry too
but both of them were calm like I was
actually doing that it's like you know I
think this is not okay and in the end
you know he actually laughs but when I
was talking to my parents like you don't
this is not okay we need to report the
police everything and then my mom and
dad asked me and then what yeah there
you go report to police and then what
like well I don't know why he missed oh
it's hard like well if you report the
police it's gonna cost more on ask us we
need to paid a lawyer when it's okay
this and this and that then and then
what why don't we pray for him Wow how
many characters in the Bible could have
the same story of a complete injustice
John the Baptist look man I was telling
the King to be moral and not you know
taking his brother's wife or whatever
and I get thrown in jail and Jesus is
out there he could save me and he
doesn't he could have every right to
stand up and be like dude this is
totally injustice right here though but
he stuck to
you know that faith and and and Jesus
didn't even go and visit him like the
bat that to me is amazing yeah like just
just see how these different characters
in the Bible this injustice is gonna
come in many different forms all the
time it's really how do we react to it
you know that's the key and we actually
don't want to react to it we want to
respond and you can only respond if
you've thought about it before because
we know the Bible says anyone that
chooses to live justly will get
persecution so we know that injustice
will come once we chose to be living
according to the will and the law of God
and so we have to think about these
things beforehand and make the decision
resolved to always stand for what is
right now well you know we spoke about
people who had injustice done to them
you talked about Jesus he talked about
John when we look back at it how did
they become who they became as adults
their upbringing you have to look at
parenting and so as I was thinking about
this I actually thought about three
critical factors that Christian
parenting should always keep in mind and
the first is that every Christian parent
should introduce their children to Jesus
Christ and they should lead their child
it's the parent who should lead the
child to accept Jesus into their heart
and surrender their life to him the past
or the minister in the church comes
after I think children should accept
Christ first from their home from the
parent leading them to Christ and the
second point is that each parent or
every parent should help their children
to develop a worldview that's eternal in
perspective affirm a worldview that
looks at what's going to happen to me in
eternity when this world ends where will
I end mhm and the third thing I thought
about was you should teach your children
to think
themselves they should not be reflectors
of other men's thoughts they should not
be followers they should be leaders
because that's what God wants his
followers to be to be the leaders a
Fisher of man leads someone a disciple
leads someone to the master and I think
if those three factors those three
principles were exercised by parents at
home in every Christian home we won't
have a lot of the things that you see
and there are lots of Christians in
these these riots there are lots of
people who are talking about the God and
talking about Christ someone goes to the
point of seeing I'll leave my
Christianity down when I'm finished with
this you know I'd pick it up and that's
not what Christianity is all about hmm
we need to teach our children to think
with an eternal perspective but in a
spiritual perspective I'm not a temporal
or physical perspective look at the the
eternal perspective somebody like Joseph
had mm-hmm
you know I mean you you've got to really
be strong in your faith to be sold into
slavery from your brothers mm-hmm lied
to by the person that you're only
helping and increasing their house
thrown in prison forgotten about and
you're still completely faithful to God
if anyone has anything to say about
injustice I'm sorry that's that's it
that's a pin right there and and so you
can go through the whole Bible Joe he
was a child
yeah when he was sold he was a child
when the Hebrew boys and Daniel were
taken into captivity they were children
they were young men and so it is
important that we prepare our children
for the life that is going to come to
them later because it will come that's
right I like how this conversation
really went back to a call for the
parents this education begins in the
home teaching the children how to react
to something like this because brothers
and sisters this is not going to go
way this is going to get worse and worse
and worse and it's like no a man no
amount of fighting is going to equal the
injustice that's coming it's been
injustice since the beginning yes so one
way that I I just love that came out of
this conversation is really educate
educate yourselves in Christ from an
early age on up and get to know that God
of the Bible just another perspective
that's what God intended for parents to
do because when we go back to
Deuteronomy chapter 6 that's what he
says that parents should teach the
commandments and teach the precepts of
God to their children it says when you
wake up when you sit by the table when
you walk by the road when you're going
to sleep write it on your door cause
that actually our notation when you look
at all of the places the examples that a
given where parents should be talking to
their children about God it really
covers the entire span of living through
one day so your parents are supposed to
introduce their children to God teach
them all of the precepts of God and make
sure that they understand have
opportunity for them to ask questions
answer the questions and when you do
that then you have children to
understand why there are Christians
they're not just going to church because
the parent said you have to concentrate
you to me today they're actually going
because they know the God that we
worship when we go to church and they
want to go because they love Jesus man
and I think that that is the foundation
for change in in humans in the world
that we live in because growing up
someone's children to grow up to be a
callous and hard an evil person
it started the seeds were sown somewhere
in the childhood and how much of that
racism is really passed down from the
parents a lot a lot you just have to
watch children play and look at when
they stop playing with other races we're
under here
in the south and I know that these are
deep family things that are passed on to
generations of kids these poor kids they
probably have never had an experience
that would make them hatred hateful but
it's been programmed into this and it's
important to allow kids to experience
truth you know so they have a balanced
worldview don't just you know sit on the
couch with them and watch the news watch
the discrimination all these things now
how about you take them on a play date
with a black family you know have them
experience the average black family that
is just really similar normal to
everyone else that's right
who's happy who was trying to build up a
life just like everyone else have have
that balance as well put on your glasses
that this is humanity I'd like to send
my deepest condolences to the family of
George Floyd and to families who have
lost loved ones previous to him because
of just the the violence and the
volatile situation that's going on in
this country here at little light
studios we're building a community at
LED live one of love and one where we
would like to be the change that we wish
to see so please if you have a story if
you have a word of encouragement if you
have a prayer that you'd like to share
leave that in the comment section below
so others can benefit as well if there's
anything that was said on the show that
you disagree with and you'd like to
share your opinion leave that as well
but please be respectful to everyone who
comes into the comment section and may
God bless each and every one of you and
specifically protect you until we see
you again have a great week guys
[Music]